for a second day this main arterial
route into central London remained
blocked off a specialist police teams
carried out a fingertip search of the
scene of Sunday's attack
we know that terrorists Sudesh a man
began stabbing people here just before
2:00 p.m. three people got startled but
we still don't know if this was his
original intended target or if he
decided to strike because he realized he
was being followed by a surveillance
team when they shot him
it was these undercover armed officers
part of that surveillance team who
opened fire fatally wounding him in
front of terrified shoppers I thought
was a mugging so I ran after what I
thought was the mugger and then I heard
what I thought was a car backfiring all
of a sudden I saw police officers
pointing what I thought was a Taser to
someone on the ground and then turned
around and just behind me there was
someone bleeding out at the Beale hostel
where pseudo Sherman had been staying
police have carried out searches and
interviewed other residents like the
fatal stabbings at London Bridge two
months ago the perpetrator in Stratham
was a former terrorist prisoner who
qualified for automatic release halfway
through his sentence it is deeply
uncomfortable for government ministers
who promise to ensure terror prisoners
will spend much longer inside in the
wake of the London Bridge attack the
Justice Secretary said that argent
action will now follows emergency
legislation to ensure an end to
terrorist terrorist offenders getting
released automatically having served
half of their sentence with no check or
review and that any release before the
end of their sentence will be dependent
upon risk assessment by the parole board
in Bishop's Stortford another address
linked to the attacker is being searched
as authorities try to determine his
motivation for Sunday's attack in a very
pessimistic
assessment of the effectiveness of
counter extremism programs the Prime
Minister stressed the need to ensure
terror offenders are properly monitored
on their release from prison the
problems we have with reeducate and
reclaiming and rehabilitating our people
who succumb to Islamism it's very very
hard and very tough and it can happen
but the instances of success are really
very few Scotland Yard said it's
surveillance officers acted extremely
quickly to stop soother Sherman on
Sunday afternoon but he dashed into a
local discount store and grabbed a knife
in just a few short seconds with the
detailed forensic examination now at an
end here the street cleaners have moved
in to prepare for the reopening of this
busy thoroughfare and a return to some
kind of normality as the police cordons
came down this evening authorities said
their ongoing investigation suggests
this was an isolated incident that there
is no wider threat to the public
mark white Sky News Stratham in South
London